Tradutor: Renan Serrano
Revisor: Claudia Sander
As tendências de moda
continuam sendo passageiras.
Elas ainda estão baseadas
na atração visual
dada apenas pelo exterior
e naquela lógica antiquada
de diferenciação
entre burguesia versus plebeus,
que se maquiou de evolução
e veio a definir grupinhos
de estilos iguais
que diferenciam quem é legal e quem não.
Na verdade, isso é uma extrema estagnação
frente a qualquer tipo de inclusão.
Pras marcas, elas querem mais
é que esse ciclo se perpetue.
Agora, pros estilistas, é uma tarefa
um tanto quanto entediante:
pesquisa, copia, modifica, reproduz.
Pra muitos, essa rotina
se repete diariamente.
Dá pra contar nos dedos
os estilista que têm no mundo
que não ficam por aí pesquisando
desfiles e exposições de arte,
como desculpa pra definir
qual vai ser o tema da próxima coleção.
Eu me considero um desses poucos sortudos,
porque eu pude perceber rapidamente
que estilista, na verdade é:
estilo-salada-mista.
(Risos)
E eu decidi não jogar fora
meus quatro anos de faculdade de moda
e não aceitar que minha vida
seria assim: vazia e repetitiva.
Pude perceber que o estilista enviesa
muito mais pra um cientista de dados:
aquele que parametriza
e analisa os fatores
que influenciam a venda
e o desenvolvimento
de novas coleções e novas soluções.
E nos últimos anos, eu venho trabalhando
com softwares de inteligência artificial
utilizando a seguinte lógica:
de um lado a gente tem a ficha técnica,
que tem o tecido, a cor, o acabamento
a forma e a função dessa roupa;
do outro, a gente tem o marketing,
que são as peças mais vendidas,
as peças mais desejadas
e também aquelas peças
que foram pro provador,
mas, por algum motivo, não foram vendidas.
Agora, a tarefa é recombiná-las,
e aí, quando isso acontecer,
o estilista vai passar a ser
a pessoa que vai decidir,
dentre todas as combinações
oferecidas pelo software,
qual é a próxima que ele vai lançar.
A mais coerente pra lançar
naquele momento.
Numa dessas análises, eu pude perceber
que o produto que eu levava
meses pra desenvolver
acabava durando anos nas araras.
Hoje, faz exatamente quatro anos
que eu não lanço um modelo novo.
E por que eu fiz isso?
Porque eu pude perceber
que o consumidor dela
leva um certo tempo pra decidir,
dentre todos os modelos oferecidos,
qual vai ser o próximo
que ele vai comprar.
Esse processo decisório,
ele não é por impulso.
É uma compra extremamente consciente
e pode levar meses pra se concretizar.
Por eu ser pequeno,
eu consegui me adaptar rápido,
mas eu percebi que esses seres pensantes
são em uma escala tão grande
que eu não consigo dar conta sozinho.
Uma coisa contraditória é o seguinte:
eu acredito que, aparentemente,
pra nenhuma marca é interessante ter
um cliente que pensa antes de comprar.
Mas não é esse tipo de pessoa,
esse ser pensante,
o que a gente valoriza quando a gente
busca alguém pra estar perto de nós?
Eu digo isso porque eu passei
a me aproximar do consumidor da marca,
e hoje já não é mais uma relação
de venda, é de amizade.
Eu passei a entender a rotina deles,
as necessidades e os padrões do cotidiano.
E com isso eu pude enxergar
que eles não querem trocar de estilo.
O que acontece é que eles estão,
continuamente, buscando
um estilo que expresse
sua coletânea interna de dados.
E também, que os exteriorize
de maneira única.
Mas, infelizmente, quando isso acontece,
as marcas simplesmente trocam
de tendência em poucos meses,
e eles ficam... órfãos.
Num ato de desespero,
eles saem correndo, comprando mais peças,
e também evitam lavá-las.
Por quê?
O tecido desgasta,
as costuras enfraquecem,
enfim, uma hora ou outra
a roupa acaba envelhecendo
e eles vão ter que enfrentar
tudo isso de novo.
Bom.
Eu fui buscar maneiras de tentar
quebrar esse ciclo de consumo,
que vem se reduzindo
de seis pra três meses.
E como o principal motivo
do envelhecimento é a lavanderia,
eu vou apresentar pra vocês agora
os principais fatores
de por que a gente lava a nossa roupa.
O primeiro é o hábito,
uma "parada" que a gente
já está há séculos
acostumada a fazer diariamente.
Outro ponto é a sujeira.
Mas você tem que concordar comigo
que, depois de um certa idade,
a gente não se suja mais todos os dias.
O odor causado por poluição e cigarro.
Que, a boa notícia é que existe
uma solução bem simples, que é:
pega essa roupa, põe no varal,
e o vento e o sol vão cumprir
a missão deles em dois ou três dias.
O maior e mais importante motivo
pelo qual a gente lava a nossa roupa
é a higiene,
causada por vírus, fungos e bactérias.
Elas estão presentes no ar
e também na nossa pele.
E durante o nosso dia, a gente fica
com receio de repetir essa roupa
porque elas podem ter se instalado lá.
Essas bactérias se alimentam
das mais sutis transpirações
que [ocorrem] nos poros da nossa pele.
E por ela estar em contato com a roupa,
essa roupa se transforma numa plataforma
pra essas bactérias
se proliferarem rapidamente.
E os excrementos da bactéria
é o tal do mau odor na roupa.
Com essas informações em mãos,
a minha missão foi desenvolver um produto
que não deixe a bactéria
se instalar na roupa.
Porque produto pra limpar,
contra bactéria,
pra matar bactéria é o que mais tem.
Mas não tem nada que proteja contra elas.
Que ele fosse, também, seguro.
Que você não precisasse de nenhum produto,
de nada pra se proteger,
nesse momento de aplicação.
Que ele fosse de matéria-prima orgânica
e, pra mim o mais importante
e foi a maior missão de todas,
encontrar uma solução que não prejudicasse
as bactérias que preservam a nossa pele,
chamadas de microbiota.
A solução que eu encontrei
não estava em produzir mais roupas
com mais tecnologias embutidas,
como eu vinha fazendo nos últimos anos.
Na verdade, eu traduzi uma tecnologia
que estava no seu ambiente industrial
e trouxe ela pra acesso
do consumidor final, das pessoas comuns.
Bom, isto aqui na minha mão
não é um aerossol
e nem precisa de gás pra se propagar.
Eu consegui traduzir essa tecnologia
num simples borrifador;
que, quando eu aplico na roupa limpa
desta maneira,
milhões de nanocápsulas
se propagam no tecido.
Essa é uma tela em que vocês podem ver
como essas cápsulas ficam na roupa.
E, pra tentar ser mais sintético
na explicação pra vocês,
funciona da seguinte maneira:
"regain" é o termo técnico utilizado
quando a gente fala do transporte
do suor e das bactérias
através dos fios e fibras do tecido.
Quando eles entram em contato
com essas cápsulas,
a função dela de proteger
contra proliferação e desenvolvimento
de bactérias é ativado.
Pra vocês terem uma noção,
eu recebi feedback de vários usuários
que conseguiram ficar
por 60 dias consecutivos
usando a mesma roupa.
Isto aqui são fotos de atletas reais
que estavam usando o produto.
Hoje, estou negociando com várias marcas
de âmbito nacional e internacional
pra eles consumirem esse produto,
mas eu percebo que a transformação real
só vai acontecer, quando houver
o consumo em massa por pessoas reais.
Aí então, o sistema
inconsequente do "fast-fashion",
o desperdício de água incoerente
na lavagem de roupa e o desgaste delas,
todos eles vão sofrer uma mudança
e vão deixar um marco na história
e todos vocês estão fazendo parte disso.
A transformação está em nossas mãos!
Esse novo jeito de pensar
me permitiu perceber que é primordial,
antes de eu criar uma peça de roupa nova,
entender o caimento do tecido
sobre o corpo humano
e também a necessidade das pessoas.
Esses dois pontos
e a sensibilidade de uni-los,
me permitiu criar produtos num tempo
que está alinhado com a nossa era.
E na minha cabeça, hoje,
eu visualizo uma escada evolutiva
e, nela, eu acredito que o próximo degrau
é a união dos "players" do mercado têxtil,
gerando nivelamento social
entre eles e os estudantes de moda.
Pra vocês terem uma noção,
no Brasil, anualmente, se formam
3 mil estudantes de moda.
Eles não estão mais
conectados com a indústria,
eles têm um conhecimento
que a indústria não quer.
E o que acontece, esse conhecimento
que eles estão tentando botar em prática
está sendo divergente da indústria.
Por quê?
De um lado os estudantes
estão se profissionalizando
com novas técnicas
e informações de mercado.
Só que do outro
a indústria têxtil, as empresas,
continua usando processos ainda oriundos
da segunda revolução industrial.
Se a gente quiser que tudo isso,
realmente, aconteça,
a gente precisa colocar na nossa cabeça
a palavra-chave "transparência"
e começar a usá-la daqui pra frente.
A gente precisa mostrar pra todo mundo
quem a gente realmente é,
mesmo que isso signifique
não saber quem a gente seja.
A gente precisa mostrar pra todo mundo
o que nos motiva
e também as nossas experiências,
mesmo que elas sejam muito poucas.
Mas pra mim, o mais importante
é que a gente deixe de se oferecer.
O que eu quero dizer com isso?
A gente tem que parar de se disponibilizar
pra vagas de emprego,
de ficar se adaptando pra elas.
A gente tem que ser um catalisador
da transformação e da inovação.
A gente tem que trabalhar ativamente
com pesquisa e desenvolvimento,
mas não aquela que a indústria têxtil
conhece hoje como:
pesquisa é ver o que estão fazendo,
e desenvolvimento é copiar pior
ou, no máximo, igual.
Pra mim, a beleza de tudo isso
está em enxergar a deficiência do outro.
Ali a gente pode proporcionar
oportunidades de colaboração
em vez de concorrência.
E aí sim, a gente pode continuar
subindo os degraus dessa vida
e encontrar uma sinergia
do nascer, viver e morrer.
Que ao meu ver,
consiste em deixar o mundo
um pouco melhor do que quando chegamos.
Obrigado.
(Aplausos)